he is the world's most famous cyclist
dominating his sport like no one before
or since
yet his reputation has forever been
tarnished by a scandal that taught at
the very fabric of professional cycling
pitting the sports elite against one
another the doping scandal however was
just one in a series of mountain-like
obstacles that have confronted Lance
Armstrong the story of how he has
overcome them is one of perseverance
tenacity and self belief and in this
week's bio graphics we explore the
tumultuous life of Lance Armstrong
[Music]
sloths Edward Armstrong was born as
Lance Gundersen in Texas on September
the 18th 1971 his mother Linda was just
17 years old and a high school dropout
while his biological father
Eddie Gunderson was a Rooter manager for
the Dallas Morning News the marriage was
an unhappy one with Eddie proving to be
abusive and neglectful they divorced
when Lance was only 2 years old
before long Linda she had remarried and
Lance's stepfather was a traveling
salesman named Terry Armstrong Armstrong
was a stern distant man who never really
bonded with Lance during his formative
years
Terry's job kept him away from home a
lot and when he was home he proved to be
a harsh disciplinarian who would beat
Lance with a paddle for any sort of
encouragement not surprisingly the boy
looked forward to his stepfathers work
trips when it was just him and his
mother a time as the years progressed
the family's finances improved and they
moved to better neighborhoods they ended
up in Richardson where Linda signed up
young Lance for swimming lessons she
also bought him a bicycle young Lance
was an active inquisitive child he often
got into fights with one scuffle getting
and kicked off the school bus after
which he rode his bicycle to school yeah
love of competitive sports though he
never really clicked with football which
was the dominant sport in Texas instead
he became passionate about her running
and swimming Lance had an abundance of
energy his favorite TV show was the Six
Million Dollar Man and he loved nothing
better than to run around the
neighborhood pretending to be the bionic
man as he chanted the words of the
show's theme song better stronger faster
from Richardson the Armstrong's moved to
Plano Texas where Linda's new job as a
telecommunications company secretary
enabled them to buy their first house it
was here that they lived through the
bulk of Lance's schooling he attended
the Armstrong middle school Williams
high and Plano East High Linda bought
her son his first serious bike when he
was 7 years old
there was a twin mag scrambler BMX
racing bike the bike along with a helmet
and safety gear cost three times what
Linda was sleeping dispensed but she saw
the value in getting her son involved in
an outdoor sport Lance
his scrambler until he was 13 when his
mother bought him mercy a road bike
while his competitive career began at
just 12 years old when he competed in
the Plano Swim Club champs he saw some
success but a year later he saw a poster
for a triathlon and decided to switch to
the three discipline event his first
triathlon was the onion kids which he
won pretty handily with his stepfather
or often absent from the home Lance
lacks a strong male role model during
his formative years barrel was filled in
his early teens by Chris mccurdy his
Plano swimming coach mccurdy trained
Armstrong right through middle school
and high school and encouraged him to
compete on a national level and even to
set his sights on the Olympics another
man who took an interest in the teenage
Lance was the owner of a local bicycle
shop and his name was Jim white he gave
the Armstrongs discounts on equipment
and Lance managed to earn some money
riding for the events that were
sponsored by height when Lance was 14 he
competed and won his first duathlon
consisting of swimming and running the
prize was a $100 pair of AVO running
shoes however when the shoes arrived in
the mail they did not fit the sales rep
who came to the Armstrong home with a
replacement pair Scot Edda
ended up taking Lance under his wing and
taking him to workouts and competitions
head up took Lance to the Cooper
Institute in Dallas when the boy was 16
the researchers there tested his vo2 max
which came out at 79.5%
it was the highest that they had ever
seen this meant that Lance had an
incredible ability to make use of every
breath of oxygen that came into his body
the testing also showed that he had the
highest lactic acid threshold that they
had ever come across there is formative
years Lance had a knack for getting
himself into quite a bit of trouble he
and his mates would sneak into the
neighbor's house and steal beer from the
fridge on one occasion he and another
boy glued the mailbox of a man who they
had argued with the police eventually
came calling when he stole an Armstrong
Street sign as an ornament for his room
when he was 16 however his mother told
him that she was planning on leaving his
stepfather
she urged Lance to stop getting into
trouble as she wouldn't be able to
handle the stress that it would bring to
her mom's responded channeling all of
his energy
into his sporting events Lanson Linda
now spent most weekends together
traveling to 10k running events and
triathlons that he competed in during
the week Lance spent many hours going on
long rides with his cycling buddies
Linda helped her son to seek out
sponsors who would supply such things as
shoes and jerseys every single sponsor
received a handwritten letter of thanks
from Lance so there are four competitive
cycling categories all riders start out
a cat for four Lance this meant Tuesday
night Criterion rides at the local bike
Mart it wasn't long before he moved up
to top 3 where he found himself training
with a couple of cat one guys when he
was 16 Lance was riding his mercy a
racing bike along the Dallas countryside
when he was apparently run off the road
by a truck driver a furious Lance cursed
at the driver from the asphalt this
caused the man to see red and he stopped
his truck and got out in a rage Lance
jump to his feet and took off but the
man trashed his bike
before he left Lance managed to record a
snubber place Linda
proceeded to sue this man and win she
used the money to buy her son a new
rally bike with racing wheels Lance's
new bike though didn't last long
not long after receiving is he was hit
by an SUV while running yellow light he
was thrown over the handlebars and onto
the hood of the SUV he was lucky to get
away alive especially since he wasn't
wearing a helmet he turned up at the
hospital with a twisted foot some
scrapes and a concussion with his foot
laced with stitches and heavy brace
Lance's doctor told him to do nothing
for the next three weeks but there was
just one problem he had a triathlon race
in six days the doctor simply told him
to forget about it
instead he got rid of the brace on the
second day cut out the stitches himself
with a nail clipper and turned up on the
starting line that Saturday he led the
swim and the ride eventually coming in
third when he heard about it the doctor
who had treated him he could hardly
believe it by the time of his final year
in high school in 1989 Lance was a
national level cycling competitor he had
qualified to train with the junior
national team at Colorado in preparation
for the World Junior Championships
throughout his high school years Lance
had missed a lot of school due to his
traveling around the countryside to
compete the school however had viewed
the absences as being on par with
playing hooky they told him that he did
not have leave to go to Colorado or
indeed to follow on to Moscow to compete
in the world championships the fact that
cycling wasn't even recognized as a
sport by Texas high schools at the time
certainly factored into their
decision-making more was to come though
despite his working overtime to meet the
requirements a meeting was called where
Lance and his mother we're told that he
would not be able to graduate with his
class that year they didn't care that he
was an emerging elite athlete with an
unprecedented opportunity to advance his
career to them Lance he was simply a
slacker
Linda soon got her son into a private
school that would let him graduate the
teachers of the new school bending Oakes
Academy were happy to work around
lancers schedule to help him complete
his schooling Armstrong's fierce
competitiveness brought in to the
attention of the coach of the US
National Cycling Team Chris Carmichael
Carmichael later noted he was so
aggressive that he they had tear the
field apart and the win or pull everyone
after him so they'd blow by him at the
ends Lance qualified for and competed in
the Junior World Champs in Moscow in
1989 this was to prove to be his
breakout year he got more attention than
others because of his aggressive racing
style he broke away from the main group
in the first lap riding in the front
peloton and was right up there until the
final thrust we're stronger riders
pushed ahead of him his performance in
Moscow in marked Armstrong as the most
exciting new cyclist on the world stage
he showed himself to be an aggressive
competitor with the ability to focus
like a laser beam on achieving his goals
he was supremely confident which was
easy to read his arrogance he also had
no interest in riding as a part of a
team he didn't want anything do to tract
him from his desire to cross the finish
line first it was in 1992 that Armstrong
competed at his first Olympics in
Barcelona he later recalled that he rode
miserably as an inexperienced hothead
and finished a disappointing 14th in the
road race his performance however it was
enough to bring him to the attention of
the director of a professional
bored steam that was sponsored by
Motorola after the games Lance first
signed onto the team which officially
made him a professional athlete under
the Motorola banner Lance traveled to
Europe in order to compete in a series
of Road races his first race was in San
sebastián Spain and he came in dead last
the crowd jeered at him when he crossed
the line 30 minutes after the winner
Armstrong was deflated after this race
and he considered flying back to the
United States but his coach convinced
him to stay and prove himself and proved
to his teammates that he was no quitter
and so well Lance stayed on from race to
race he got better and he came in second
of the Zurich Championships finally
telling himself that he was capable of
doing this one of lances biggest
challenges with Motorola was learning to
work as part of a cycling team he would
quickly get frustrated with the other
riders in his palate and yelling at them
to pull or get out of the way the
veterans would try to frustrate him on
purpose encouraging him to take the lead
and wear himself out early after only 12
months as a professional cyclist Lance
had already earned the nickname the king
at the 1993 UCI Track Cycling World
Championship in Oslo Norway the Motorola
team decided that he was ready to take
the title and as they would work with
him to win the race rather than rushing
to the lead he stayed in the peloton
until the second-to-last lap as he had
been instructed doomed then he attacked
to take the lead and stay there he
crossed the line well ahead of the
competition and he bowed to the crowd
blew kisses and in what was to become
his trademark he pointed to the sky
Armstrong he was now the world champion
but to truly be the best he knew that he
had to win the Tour de France in 1995 he
won a stage of the world's greatest race
dedicating the win to a teammate who had
died during a crash in that very race in
August of 1996 he signed a two-year
contract with the prophetís cycling team
in France
[Music]
in 1996 Lance noticed that his right
testicle was becoming swollen this was
followed by a dull ache and then a lack
of energy this affected his performance
at the 96 Olympics Indy had a
disappointing finish in his memoirs he
recalled that he felt like he was
dragging a manhole cover during the road
race in October after returning from the
Olympics Armstrong was diagnosed with
testicular cancer he had put off seeing
a doctor but when he began coughing up a
blood he knew that he had to act the
news it rocked Armstrong as well as his
support team he was 25 an elite athlete
and had stage 3 testicular cancer that
had spread to his brain his lungs and
his abdomen his chances of survival were
estimated to be below 50 percent and it
looked pretty likely that he would never
race again
despite recently signing a 2.5 million
dollar contract with coffered s his
team's lawyers decided that they would
not provide insurance covering his
treatments as the condition had not been
advised at the time of the signing of
the contract there were sponsors however
who did not abandon Armstrong during his
time of need
Oakley even offered for him to be
covered under their health plan
Armstrong took on the cancer challenge
with the same fierce determination that
had made him a world champion he
underwent a program of intense
chemotherapy treatments he sought out
and began treatment with a very caustic
chemo cocktail known as VIP which was
less damaging on the lungs than
conventional treatments this choice it
probably saved his cycling career
throughout his chemo treatments
Armstrong competed sporadically
understandably he did not do well but he
was keeping himself in the game the
final chemo treatments it took place on
December the 13th 1996 and in February
of 1997 his doctors were able to confirm
that his cancer was in full remission
[Music]
Armstrong returned to competitive
cycling at the beginning of 1998 his
contract with Cofidis had been cancelled
in 1997 and he had signed on with the US
Postal Service cycling team he moved to
Europe with the team to train for the
Tour de France Armstrong was now
recognized as the
poster child for being a cancer survivor
he received many awards and many titles
throughout 1998 he built successes one
upon another and he steadily improved
displacing that year he also married his
fiancee Kristen Richard the marriage
would last five years and it would
produce three children Armstrong won his
first Tour de France in 1999 he won four
stages and had learned to work well with
his teammates he finished the race seven
minutes and 37 seconds ahead of the
second-place finisher in a post win
interview he proclaims if you get a
second chance at life for something go
all the way in 2000 Armstrong came back
to France determined to defend his title
the race turned out to be a battle
between him and young Ulrich who had
competed the previous yeah this rivalry
was to continue for the next five yes
Armstrong crossed the finish line
six minutes ahead of Ulrich to become a
two-time champion Armstrong dominated
the cycling world in the early 2000 his
consecutive run of Tour de France
victories stretched on to an
unprecedented seven in a row from 1999
to 2005 following his July 24 2005 when
he announced his retirement from
competitive cycling
[Music]
in the wake of his stunning 1999 Tour de
France victory there were allegations
that Armstrong must have been involved
in either drug taking or blood doping in
early 2000 under the auspices of the
Nike operation he created a documentary
stolid virtus meant entitled body in
order to answer that attracters the film
focused on his steely will to win and
showed footage of him undergoing drug
tests the voice-over narration it was
done by Armstrong himself at one point
he says everybody wants to know what I'm
on what am i on I'm on my bike busting
my ass six hours a day what do you want
when results came through that he had
tested positive for a minut amount of
corticosteroid after the 99 Tour de
France many people doubled down on their
accusations but the amounts in his body
were so my knew that they were not
enough to fail the test since that one
little blip he has never failed a drug
test there has however been quite a lot
of circumstantial evidence in 2004 a
book was published called
LA Confidential which claimed that
Armstrong had been using
performance-enhancing drugs it quoted
from Steve Swart a former Motorola
teammate who claims that all the team
members were using as far back as 1995
when allegations made in the book were
reprinted in the British newspaper The
Sunday Times Armstrong sued them leading
to an out-of-court settlement in June of
2012 the US anti-doping agency brought
allegations against Armstrong of running
a huge doping ring among his teammates
during his competitive career they were
armed with testimony from a number of
former teammates their goal was to have
him banned from any sport that followed
the world anti-doping code Lance he did
not appeal the ban Armstrong continued
to vehemently deny the allegations of
doping until 2013 then in a bombshell
interview with Oprah Winfrey he admitted
that he had used performance-enhancing
drugs for all of his Tour de France wins
he claimed to have used erythropoietin
and human growth hormone and to have
engaged in blood doping the reaction it
was one of outraged parties began lining
up to sue Armstrong including teammates
that he had called liars and parties
that he had won libel suits against
US Justice Department sued him for
millions of dollars that the US Postal
Service had spent on sponsorship the
world cycling governing body a few day a
lifetime ban to Armstrong he still
competes in amateur events however today
he owns a coffee shop in Austin Texas
and a bike shop called Mellow Johnny's
though he won't never shake the
reputation as the world's greatest
cycling cheat he has built a life for
himself that allows him to indulge his
cycling passion and his competitive
nature as an amateur athlete following
his successful cancer treatments
Armstrong started the Lance Armstrong
Foundation it began with a fundraising
race to raise money for cancer research
one of the most successful initiatives
of the foundation was the production in
2004 of a silicon bands imprinted with
the words LIVESTRONG over 80 million of
these bracelets have been sold worldwide
so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic if you did there's
a couple of things you could do right
now one is hit that like button below
also if you want more stuff like this we
put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every month enters they won't
put out a new video also if you want to
watch something else right now stuff
from the archive over there on the right
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]